[Music]  gentlemen we are smokejumpers the most  elite team of firefighters in the world  he must be in our very best what I say  we do now go for extraction  we can get you back to your parents I'm  legally bound to take care yet so that's  why I'm gonna do an intern you're gonna  be obedient so we can do our job and  when you do this when you go like Oh  like that it's not helpful  Oh soon anagen is under my watch we buy  your man can't turn my neck what needs  to happen this second is you got to  watch your tone little sister or what  masher is coming to rock you work what  just happened I think the baby just  broke a dog so I get distracted I can't  do this job effectively don't you  remember what it's like to be a kid  well now it's a party  what kind of firefighters are you I know  you don't see it but he has a sweet side  oh what a rush  boom-boom-boom-boom look at me don't do  it around it  [Music]